Italy has just recorded a large jump in
coronavirus deaths and increase its
official number of cases to more than
2,500 it was already Europe's worst hit
country this makeshift triage center has
been set up at a hospital in Brescia to
keep suspected kovat 19 patients
separate from others the National Health
Institute wants a new quarantine redzone
set up near Bergamo that would make
three in Italy's north as the UK updated
its number of confirmed coronavirus
cases 251 signs of the outbreaks impact
are starting to show there this pub in
Surrey closed for a deep-clean
after someone with the virus visited but
on the day the government unveiled its
action plan it's clear the UK is trying
not to overreact let me be absolutely
clear that for the overwhelming majority
of people who contracted the virus this
will be a mild disease from which they
will speedily and fully recover as we've
already seen but I fully understand
public concern for the moment no blanket
school closures no major reorganisation
of health services no army involvement
no advisories against travel not unless
things get significantly worse if you do
it too early you end up with a lot of
people having disruption Europe's big
carriers are meeting at an aviation
conference in Brussels this chief
executive thinks airlines are going to
be hit hard by flight cancellations
there are quite a few weak carriers
throughout the world and in particular
Asia and so we are seeing that in Europe
we've we see the same France over the
last few months you've seen two failures
so most definitely I believe this will
accelerate consolidation in France
we're worried staff closed the Louvre
Museum on Sunday and Monday the
government is to requisition face masks
there's been a run on them in shops and
prices have risen we will distribute
them to health professionals and to
French people infected with the corona
virus president micron said on Twitter
Rory challenged how do
zerah